hello everyone
welcome to the
d mice informatics conference and i
guess welcome to some number of people
who are out there uh watching by
streaming as i did from riyadh saudi
arabia uh last a couple weeks ago
anyways um we have a
speaker
from
a visitor today from from massachusetts
and so
we'll
just that this conference isn't always
just
us talking to ourselves in fact we have
another
visiting speaker tomorrow morning i i
know it kind of came about with short
notice but
you can find the flyers about it
around the building anyway so um i'd
like to introduce our speaker
jenna marquardt who
is currently at the university of
massachusetts in amherst
she graduated from the university of
iowa in 2003 with a bachelor's degree in
industrial engineering and then
pursued graduate studies in that field
at university of
wisconsin-madison and worked under the
supervision of a very good friend of
mine
and very good friend of many viewers
dr patty brennan
and
conducted research in areas of consumer
health informatics decision making and
health information exchange and for the
last six years she's been at umass
amherst and her current research uses
methods from engineering psychology
visualization and computer science
fields to understand consumers and
providers information search and
decision-making patterns she's funded in
her research by the national science
foundation and the agency for healthcare
research and quality which funds a fair
amount of work in this department
and
she's
she's
visiting here today and is going to do a
sabbatical here
this fall
and so you'll get a little
introduction today and then if you're
interested
maybe you can
spend more time with her in the fall so
i will turn it over to jenna
thank you so much for the introduction
bill
i'm thrilled to be here today
for a variety of reasons
excited to be able to come back this
fall and so
i'm hoping that this talk spurs some
discussions in terms of fun things that
we might be able to work on and
also spurs discussions with folks in
terms of having
meetings while i'm here but again really
interested
in talking to you about three things the
first thing is i want to give you some
background about
who i am and where i'm coming from i'm
an engineer and so i have a slightly
different background than quite a few of
you and so i want to
give you a high level overview of the
types of work that my group does
and
why i think industrial engineering is an
important part of the types of things
that we're all interested in and then
want to talk specifically kind of at a
high level about a few different
projects that we're working on to give
you some sense for
how this vision that we have is played
out in in terms of the actual work that
we do
so when my group thinks about what our
vision is we're really thinking about
improving health right like all of us
are by improving decision making and the
decision decision-making of consumers
providers whether that be physicians or
nurses
um and when we think about health we
think about that happening on a
continuum and so that could be
health-related activities that happen in
a person's home or outside of
traditional care settings as they're
self-managing diseases or recovering
from acute episodes of care we also
think about that happening in routine
office visits in primary care settings
and we think about that
in inpatient settings and acute
treating acute
conditions or
incidents that come up so as we think
about health and improving decision
making we're really thinking about that
in a variety of contexts
in terms of our approach we're really
thinking about
to improve decision making how we can
provide the right information
at the right time and in the right
format
and oftentimes but not always that's
involving some type of health
information technology or informatics
intervention but not always so we're
thinking about
decision-making
when it does and when it doesn't involve
those types of technologies
from an industrial engineering
perspective and a cognitive science
perspective we know that there's this
tension when we think about decision
making that individuals are capable of
making really complicated decisions we
can see patterns in information a lot of
times we can make inferences about
things in a really
complicated and complicated ways but on
the other side of that spectrum we also
have really limited information
processing capabilities in some ways and
so there's this tension between well
we're really good at making decisions in
some ways and we're really limited in
some of the things that we can do
so
health information technology or
informatics interventions might be able
to help people
overcome some of these limitations so
that's the the framework that we're
coming coming from when we think about
our projects
so something that a lot of you are very
familiar with is charles friedman
proposed not too long ago
his fundamental theorem of informatics
right so the thinking that when we're
talking to this community we're not
thinking that computers or informatics
interventions are replacing people we're
thinking about the idea that a person
plus this intervention or tool
can do something more than that person
could do alone
and
as i talk through our projects today i'm
going to reference back to the general
structure of what this looks like as a
context or framework
what i want to point out or bring to
bring to mind is that industrial
engineers and human factors experts in
particular
have known this for a really long time
and it's actually a guiding premise of a
lot of the things that they do
and not only do
does that community know this but they
have methods and approaches to help
address this or make it a reality
but this talk is about interdisciplinary
research and so we think about as
industrial engineers one of our big
challenges is that we don't work in
isolation
and so we need teams of people
that can come together to
determine what are
clinically relevant problems if that's
if we're in the healthcare domain
to take full advantage of potential
evaluation strategies so human factors
approaches are part of that but there's
other strategies from disciplines that
can be helpful
and then to more easily disseminate the
results of our work so we think about
identifying relevant problems
putting together a whole slew of tools
that we could use to address those
problems and then disseminating them
back to the to the right communities
so again we think about this as a
spectrum and really to do this
interdisciplinary teams can add quite a
bit
i've put up here and this is an
exhaustive list but the folks that i've
had the
honor or opportunity to work with while
i've been at the university of
massachusetts and i primarily primarily
work with people from for other domains
than mine
work with great physician colleagues
nursing colleagues
folks from computer science in a lot of
our work and then
physicians whose
core responsibilities are now in
informatics
so again this is not the
whole group of people i've had the
opportunity to work with but just to
just to give some overview of the types
of folks that i've been able to work
with and as i talk through these
projects i'll i'll point back to which
of these folks has been involved in each
of the projects
so i want to return to this idea of
a year in the life of of someone and how
decisions unfold as we think about that
as the as a context
the first thing that i want to think
about are
folks that are self-managing say chronic
diseases or conditions outside of the
formal care environment
so if we look back or think back about
this fundamental theorem of informatics
this could take a variety of forms so it
might be a single individual using some
type of technology or intervention being
able to do something
that they couldn't before so do
something take actions change behaviors
or make decisions uh in in a better way
than they could have without that
it also might look like a team of people
so it could be an individual and their
informal caregiver so family or friends
different folks that are helping them
manage health in some way using an
informatics intervention
or it could be an individual in their
care team
trying to accomplish accomplish some
task or make some decision on
using an informatics intervention or
health i.t tool in a way in a better way
than they might have without
that my life in 2012 actually looked a
lot like this so the first the first two
examples i'll give are
simple things from my life that played
out and aligned with these concepts
really well
so
i've owned for several years uh the
withings scale and the basic concept of
this is it's hooked up to your home
wireless network and every time you step
on it it sends that data to
your smartphone your app or your um
tablets your
computers so it's it's sending it
wherever you need it and aggregating it
could be good it could be scary uh
whatever your whatever your thoughts are
so
this was basically 2012 for me
any any guesses on what happened right
there
i was pregnant yeah
so um
what was interesting about this is that
i would go into
see a midwife or a nurse
every month
and they appeared to be very concerned
about my weight
in terms of they would take care to
measure it they would enter it in places
it seemed like this was an important
thing to them and yet
i'm showing up at different times of
year different times a day wearing
different clothes and so i'm not
convinced it's good data and yet they're
they're
providing me this sense that this is
really important
so i've been doing this for a long time
and i kept um
monitoring this during the time that i
was pregnant and basically what this
what this gave me was some sense that
things were okay right i had shortened a
feedback loop and basically gotten
information more frequently than i was
before
and was feeling like it was much more
reliable data
so in this case this was really simple i
had one type of data that for me was
serving as a proxy that things were
going that things were going okay so it
wasn't even necessarily
this data it was the meaning behind this
data so that i was eating okay that the
baby was doing good those kinds of
things
again this is me acting alone i wasn't
sharing this data with anyone it was
just me looking at it
and getting some some sense that things
were okay
then edison comes along so dressed him
in a in a shirt that is that is portland
relevant relevant
um
so
he comes along in november of 2012
and
any new parent will realize that things
feel a little bit out of control and so
had found this application that allowed
you on your smartphone or tablet again
it was synced from whatever devices that
you
wanted to and it would allow you to
really easily
log when you were
feeding him
when you were changing his diapers when
you were
when he was sleeping all different kinds
of of data you could log really easily
and
what this helped us do in in a variety
of different contexts and again this was
we would
we would go in to see a provider
and they would
make it seem like there were certain
things that were really important and so
they would ask us questions about how
often you know he was eating and how
often we were changing his diaper and
these kinds of things and we didn't have
data
right except for this so this made that
conversation a whole lot easier and then
we would be traveling and we could
really easily
maintain awareness of when things were
happening so it was helping us
get some sense for for how things were
going the other thing it did was help
with mental health and so things change
slowly and it doesn't feel like much is
changing
but wanted to show those early morning
hours and this is a difference of about
a month and a half and how different our
life became over the course of that
month and a half so we could actually
really look back
and see how much things had changed
and that provided a lot of relief again
very simple
set of data
but this is that second example where
it's myself as a care provider an
informal care provider
for
edison my son and together we're using
this intervention and it's helping um in
a way that
just just i couldn't i couldn't do
myself
the third example of an individual
interacting with their care team
is a research project i'm going to
describe so this is we're shifting away
from from my life to one of our research
projects again but still looking at
self-managing outside the home
this is a project with
a few different organizations so barry
saver
at the top is a primary care physician
who works at umass medical school
peggy prusi is a nurse who works at a
group called reliant medical group a
practice of about
20 clinics and about 200 physicians in
central massachusetts and then mike
kelleher and larry garber are also
physicians at that practice
larry is the is the practicing the lead
of their informatics group there
so this is our this is our team that's
looking at this project it's a hrq
funded project
controlling diabetes using inexpensive
health i.t really in the context of
diabetes hypertension in diabetics so
again slightly we're measuring
hypertension in diabetics this is an
area of significant interest to the
primary care physician
that i interact with
so the goal of this was to do a
randomized control trial of an
intervention
that
would do a few things one was support
patient provider management of
hypertension and diabetics so again
we're going back to this idea of an
individual plus their care team but
still self-management at home outside of
formal care settings
from a human factor standpoint we want
this to require minimal workload on the
behalf of the patient and provider we
know that's a big deal
it was a significant interest to me to
try to use off-the-shelf technology
mainly because then it could be more
inexpensively implemented
perhaps in other settings and regardless
of what platforms they had in place
whether it was
you know epic or cerner or nextgen
or no ehr at all that this could be
replicated and disseminated in some way
so these were the guiding kind of
principles of the project
the structure of it was that we used
an off-the-shelf electronic blood
pressure cuff in omran cuff
and at the time
it was still relatively new
microsoft health vault which is
basically
an aggregator of data it'll connect with
devices and applications
and what reliant medical group was able
to do
was take the information
from healthvault and it could come in in
two ways one would be the person was
self-monitoring at home and a connection
had been set up so that when they
plugged in their cuff the data would
automatically go to health fault so that
was one option this was a dissemination
grant so we wanted to provide a
secondary option for people that either
didn't have access to home internet or
computer or people that didn't feel
comfortable doing that so we also put in
place kiosks at the clinic where they
could bring in their cuff and
upload the readings to health vault
there
in terms of workload we really didn't
want people to have to go out to a site
to get this data we wanted it to be
pretty well integrated into their
clinical workflow and so the folks at
reliant were able to build an interface
between health fault and their epic ehr
and so
automatically without doing anything
when this data was brought into health
fault it would automatically go into a
clinical flow sheet
and the value of that was that we could
set up
rules and alerts based on that data so
folks wouldn't have to actually go
go and look at proactively look at it
so they got both summaries of data
um
and triggers if there was something that
was happening that they needed to know
about
there's pretty good protocols in place
for medication changes and things like
and things like that so the primary care
physicians had okayed the protocols to
have a team of diabetes care nurses call
patients when they saw things going on
and adjust medications as needed so when
they would do that they would call
and first obviously sort of troubleshoot
if it was some kind of life issue
someone had passed away they were going
through some kind of
life change or um if this was sort of a
legitimate pattern that was happening
and then they would adjust medications
according to these protocols
so
we've just completed exit interviews for
all of the folks in the randomized
control trial but have done interviews
with patients we've done home
observations with patients interviews
with the diabetes care nurses
and
we also so we had an intervention and
control group and the folks that were in
the intervention after exiting they
could choose to keep using the
intervention and folks in the control
group could start to use it
and we've had
a huge percentage of folks that were in
the intervention group and have decided
to keep using the system
so from a
patient perspective
and we did again home observations to
try to change as much as we could to
make this as easy as easy to use as
possible
but they're wanting to keep using it
the diabetes care nurses and primary
care physicians of these patients are
incredibly happy with it
they're willing to keep using it and
there's been
basically three different
elements of this that they've found
valuable
one is that they've shortened the cycle
in which they're getting data and this
is a similar thing
in terms of when i'm talking about
things but instead of going three months
between getting data points on these
patients they're going perhaps a week or
even sooner so they're getting much more
rapid cycles and they're
they're noting that their confidence
level in the data is strengthened
because of that
the other thing has been that they've
been able to view this in multiple ways
so
we haven't required that patients have
gone to look at their data that hasn't
been part of it if they haven't wanted
to but they're doing that and the
ability to see
trends in what's going on and the same
thing with with providers has been an
important piece of this the other thing
that this has been helpful for
is if a
if the
diabetes care nurse and the patient are
having a conversation about deciding
whether to change medications
patients in their perspective from their
perspective have been much more open to
doing that because it becomes a shared
decision where they're both looking at
similar data
and so that's been helpful
so for a variety of reasons
again getting data has helped these two
sets of folks together
make in their impression make better
decisions than they would have before
again we've just done the exit interview
so we'll have actual clinical data about
whether this is improved outcomes
luckily there's about a 70 percent
overlap between this reliant medical
group and the insurance carrier for most
of the folks so we're going to get
claims data and all kinds of other
markers that we can look at
they move to routine office visits i'm
going to talk about another project that
we're working on barry savor is also
involved in this the primary care
physician at unf medical school
and another one of my colleagues at
umass
does work in human factors he does work
in the field of driver behavior and
transportation human factors and what's
been really helpful is he brings has
brought in a set of
data collection methods and
analysis methods that have been really
interesting to think about bringing in
from that domain into
the healthcare setting and there's a
pretty significant overlap with some of
the work that's going on here
so this was a or is a project we're in
the middle of
funded through the national science
foundation so for engineers this is a
pretty typical organization that funds
our research
and what we're really looking for is how
we can model
how physicians in primary care settings
search for and use information from ehrs
we're looking at how that is different
or similar across several ehr vendor
platforms and the real question that
we're trying to think about is in
addition to making these advancements in
methodology for capturing and analyzing
this type of data we're also trying to
figure out basically
if
information search patterns when say an
individual comes in for a primary care
office visit are platform dependent
meaning they change based on the design
of the specific software system
or whether they're platform agnostic
meaning that perhaps they have an
information search pattern that they
want to execute and then regardless of
the design of the system they go and
execute that search pattern so again
we're trying we're trying to get some
grass it's probably going to be in the
middle somewhere but trying to get some
understanding of it so it's both that
and trying to advance
methodologies and how we capture and
analyze this data
so
the site that we've um completed to date
is a is a community clinic that uses
nexgen
which is a lower cost system that's
often sold to
community
clinics
it's about the most horrible piece of
software that i've ever seen in my life
so
we've
the gist of this is we use an eye
tracker slightly different than the one
that's used here it's a mobile eye eye
tracker and basically it's a head
mounted eye tracker
that a person can be in a free moving
environment and we've used it in a lot
of
non-health i.t studies but we're using
it in this context in
outpatient clinics when we go there
so basically we can put this on a
physician and then have them complete
some task with the ehr in the
environment that they work in
and then when we get that data it's
basically a video
and it shows exactly the scene in front
of them and then where they're looking
at given points in time
so this is a sample
screen from nextgen
in the context of we're dealing with a
pretty stand routine office visit for a
patient with a couple chronic conditions
in the context of that visit there's
20 about 24 standard screens that they
navigate through
to complete that office visit both in
information retrieval and data entry
and when we've looked at the subjects so
far
there's 24 screens but a lot of them
they visit multiple times throughout the
throughout the visit and so
the range in terms of in terms of number
of screens visited for the subjects
ranges from about 85 to about 150
on the visits and so they're
they're searching through and entering
data in a huge number of screens so what
we're in the middle of analyzing is this
eye tracker data and to look at
sequences
in terms of what information they're
looking at and so we can get that
we're also interested in
sort of novel ways of analyzing that so
a lot of times eye tracker studies will
look at
common places that someone looked or
whether they looked at a piece of
information and we're really trying to
understand the process by which they
look at information
and if we can do that we can think about
common transitions between different
types of information and if you had
20 people who always looked at things in
the same order you could start to make
inferences about placement of different
types of information by each other so
again we're trying to think about trying
to think about what's going on
i've also done
interviews and
surveys of these
folks the part the people that
participated and as you might expect
the common theme is basically they're
trying to build a story right what's the
story of what's going on
and the way that things are structured
right now isn't helping them
because information is so disjointed
basically
so they bring up things like
even if i know something is important if
i know it's hard to find i don't go and
look for it
um so they so that again that would be a
sense for
i've got some predetermined information
search pattern that i want to execute
but the technology isn't allowing me to
do that easily but again
trying to think about what story they're
trying to understand or build and then
working backwards and trying to figure
out how can we
structure the information in a way that
allows them to build that more
efficiently
in terms of hospitalizations and sort of
acute care settings
we're looking at this idea of a care
team using some type of
health i.t
the project again with my
co or collaborator in industrial
engineering don fisher and then
the
informaticist at bay state healthcare
pat brown
he's been a hugely wonderful person to
work with he has
degrees in psychology and then was
trained as a physician so completely
understands human factors and the value
of that so it's been great great in
terms of a collaborator in this type of
work
so one of one of the projects again
funded by national science foundation
that we're in the middle of
is looking at
based you know just had a short
conversation with folks looking at how
individuals read progress notes in ehrs
so we're trying to understand
information search patterns so
transitions between different types of
information
what information they're focused on most
that kind of thing
i'm assuming you probably all could
come to a hypothesis right now about
what's going to happen but trying to
really understand the tension between
volume of information in a note
and
format of data in the note where they're
looking time spent and how all of those
impact the process by which they read
the note so
are they thinking about narrative text
different than structured data
is placement
important is volume of information
important
so
they have cerner
and this is a screenshot of
an anonymized progress note from their
system
if you were just going to do
you know you could from a sort of hci
human computer interaction perspective
you could look at this and make
80 changes without much effort just in
terms of kind of known heuristics so
there's lots of problems they know
there's lots of problems but we're
interested in
somebody designed this in this way and
what are how are they looking through
this information when they when they
read progress notes the red outlines are
not in
their system it's just the text but
we're defining what these different
areas of the note are they're all the
same structure so you know what you'd
expect demographics
vital signs that kind of thing and then
at the bottom is the impression and plan
generated by
gender rated by the person i wrote the
note
so one of the things that we saw
was that
volume of
information in a section actually has no
relationship
with how much time they spend reading
something so
we had two
very or three very different notes that
folks read and they basically would read
a note they could take as long as they
wanted and then they dictated a verbal
handoff or summary of that so we would
have some anchor in terms of with what
they looked at versus what they said was
important
so
one of the things that you'll note the
the interesting pieces of this really
were in medications and impression and
plan
so basically what we noticed was that
regardless of how much text there was
relatively in the impression and plan
that was where they spent their time
reading and
no matter how much text was in the
medications
they
hardly ever read it or they spent very
little of their time reading it
one other way to look at this was is
with these timeline graphs and you can
actually see
pretty interestingly so these are three
different notes and different subjects
here as examples there's actually a
pretty similar structure in terms of how
they go through this so
quickly skimming through different
sections
getting to the impression and plan and
then potentially referencing back
sections they think are interesting
um
the
most interesting thing or one of the
most interesting things is in
the second note
about
let's see if we can go back to this so
in that note about 50 percent of the
characters or volume of that note was in
the medication profile so it took up a
huge amount of the note and there's
actually not a lot of distinguishable
difference in how much time people spent
looking at it or not looking at that
there's a cut you know there's a couple
folks that just hardly looked at it at
all
in note 2 the second one
the impression and plan was only about
12
of the note volume
but a huge amount of the time was spent
looking at that and not only then we
looked at time right but then it's
basically rate of looking at the
information so they're slowing way down
when they go to look at that information
so again one way again with these eye
tracker videos to think about
you know what's going on in terms of the
order in which they're looking at things
and that and what what they're feeling
like is important to look at and
again you could have hypothesized right
away that when they go to read notes
they're
they have a huge reliance on
narrative and the impression and plan
and we get confirmation of that from
from interviews with folks
um
one of the interesting things that came
out of this is that in one of the notes
there was an elevated
lab value
and it wasn't noted in the impression
and plan and so none of the subjects
noticed it
and so
what's interesting about this is then
potential issues can keep moving forward
because
you're going from one narrative to the
next and so think about this like a
telephone game where things
potentially if we're not if we're over
relying on one source of data
we might be doing that at the expense of
not not seeing other kinds of
information
so
when we think back about this again
i want to really think about the fact
that this is
building some kind of story right in all
of these cases so
the issue is though that that story
differs a lot based on the context
so back at the beginning in my case the
story was about just me
and it was about one type of data and
that was an important story for me i
didn't need narrative journals i didn't
need to have
feedback on this
i could have
but i didn't need to and so again this
was a very simple story line for me that
worked
again in the case of
caring for edison after he was born
a few more types of data
again
not narrative it's discrete data it's
really important
but again very simple
just sort of our family involved in this
we would bring this in our tablet into
our pediatrician and when they started
asking us questions we would pull up the
reports on it and just give them the
answers so there was
it was useful but we weren't sharing the
information we just had it had access to
it
when we think about the case with
patients self-monitoring
their
high blood pressure their blood pressure
outside of a formal care setting
again this is
one type of data
it's discrete data
but there's a couple differences now
it's being shared with care providers
and now there's shared decision making
happening
and again it's
it's not narrative
so it was very important in order to not
increase workload that we figure out
some way to understand the story in a
way that's relevant without increasing
workload we might glean additional
information by patients sending
narrative journal reports about how
they're feeling in their emotional
well-being but in this context it was
valuable
to just have a very simple set of
data when we move though to the
primary care physicians
all of a sudden
not all those all of a sudden but
they're
gathering a whole slew of data and a lot
of what they want is narrative data
so they'll they'll go back and look at
their past notes about the patient
they'll go and look at reports from
specialists
um and so they while they're while they
are looking at when you have lab values
done
whether they should order tests whether
you need immunizations
they are
wanting a lot in in narrative form so
that starts to get a lot more complex in
terms of how they're building the story
that they want to build
similarly then when we move to
progress notes it shifts almost all the
other all the way in the other direction
where they're relying almost
exclusively on narrative data and
they've moved away from
wanting to look at
discrete data
again they're building another type of
story
with and using different kinds of data
to do that
so one of the points just kind of in
summarizing and going going through
these projects is
thinking about the fact that
when we
try to understand information search
patterns in order to make decisions we
need to be very sensitive to context
and
what that is in some cases we actually
might try to make things more
complicated than they need to be
where something simple would be helpful
and in other cases we've
simplified things where they really need
complexity in terms of
merging different kinds of data
so
again just a very high level overview of
the types of some of the projects that
we're working on i wanted to leave time
for discussion today um
but to give you some sense of the types
the types of things that we're
interested in and working on
and i'll end with i never talked about
images
as
an important type of type of information
but we also we also think about about
how those those play into this so i'll
leave it at that and
take time for questions
yeah
thank you and and let me ask anyone
who's in the room here who doesn't
normally attend to if you ask a question
to
hold down the mic but not not so much
for us to hear but for the recording and
the people who might be out there
listening who can also send us questions
via twitter if they would like um mike i
was um well interested in all three but
um uh the one on uh physician notes uh
uh probably for those of us who are
physicians are interested one of the
challenges
i almost consider to be the holy grail
of informatics is
the uh the data that uh we capture from
physicians that you know we in
informatics talk about secondary use and
clinical decision support um and to
really do that kind of stuff while you
need structured data
but
it's become clear
much uh very prominently clear as as we
adopt more ehrs
that physicians really like to read
notes and and they actually don't trust
uh check boxes and things like that i'm
wondering if your uh research has any
insights into that um
debate or or conversation
yeah so when we've had conversations
with folks i think this goes back to an
interesting
distinction and
challenge between
what the motivations are for the
production of the note
versus
the
desires in terms of using the note and
so
in this case in their platform they
actually haven't
separated those things whatever's
produced is shown
so
so there's a an acknowledgement
that
the rationale for the production of the
note
might be
a
resident who wants to include as much as
possible so that they
don't get in trouble
for leaving something out which in their
case is happening quite a bit
um
and so there's the ability in their
system like a lot of places to
with very little effort
get the structured data
and automatically populate the note with
it
so i think so i think in in in some ways
and not completely answering your
question but i think there's an issue
around
what we're capable of producing
and
in different contexts what people
want from that so it might be that
researchers are really interested in
that data from one perspective
it might be that
a nurse who's supporting things is
interested in it from a different
perspective
the physician taking over might be
interested from a different perspective
perspective and so i think
in some ways that's what's being lost is
the
needs assessment and assessment of
actually the end user
of what's helpful to them instead of
what's produced
is in full
shown
in the same way
no matter what no matter what you want
yeah
so i have a question about this search
this search pattern uh
thing interested me trying to infer what
the pattern is so uh it while you were
talking about that i was reminded of
elstein's work on hypothetical deductive
reasoning
and in your work have you been able to
get at
the degree to which the search pattern
is sort of standard like first i always
look at this then i was like that then
they looked that versus um prompted by
some
need to explain an anomaly or need to
achieve some kind of coherence
yeah so so there's a couple different
perspectives on this i didn't talk about
this but some of the
some of the preliminary work for this
was not in
health i.t specifically so we had looked
at
i work with some folks who are very
interested in patient safety and things
like
doing things to the wrong patient giving
them the wrong medication
that kind of thing so
so they had
devised some experiments and used the
eye tracker where
nurses and physicians
lab techs all kinds of different folks
did tasks that they would do every day
and they had the eye track ground so we
could see what they were looking at and
the way that they did this was that in
the last trial
they had
the person who they were supposed to be
giving a medication to let's say for the
nurse
was different than who it should have
been given for
and again these folks
knew they're in an experiment
knew that they've got the eye tracker on
and about in the case of the nurses
about 40 percent of them didn't identify
this error
so
our group came in and is we're
interested in trying to understand again
this the process of visual scanning
so we came in and
used these eye tracker videos and we
were interested in
sort of post hoc we know we've got a
group of people
that identified this error and we know
we have a group of people that didn't
can we figure out differences in their
visual scanning patterns
and so we developed a bunch of metrics
and looked at that and essentially there
is a big difference so you have multiple
identifiers on different artifacts so
name and date of birth and medical
record number and basically the people
that identify errors are
looking at one identifier across
artifacts and the people that don't
identify it are looking at everything on
an artifact trying to remember it and
then looking at everything on the next
one so we pretty easily basically
at the end able to
look at this and figure out visual
scanning differences so that got us
interested in this idea of
could we use some similar
um
ways of looking at things to do that
so
one of the things that we're interested
in is
at the end and this so this is so two
pieces of this
for
groups of say physicians that with the
same task
choose different
plans going forward
are there search patterns within the
records fundamentally different so are
there different search patterns that
lead them to go in two different
directions or multiple directions with a
patient
so we've collected the data that's what
we're looking at right now
i don't think we can get at
what you're talking about paul without
interviews and observations
so
that's where
mo a lot of our work to date has been
focused on
how we can capture this data and analyze
it
and interviews and observations have
been sort of
post hoc not aligned with that
and we've been fully aware that that's a
limitation and
are now starting to address it so no i
mean i think it's i think you just can't
do it without
talking to people and that just hasn't
been
we've known it's important but
we've concentrated in a different area
um
to do with the story so
story seems to be a theme part of the
story here you mentioned it in several
places that people were trying to
construct a story or get the story or
understand the story
is there is there a way to tell when
they
have or haven't accomplished that
when they've gotten to a state where
story has happened
so
that's been part of the goal
in doing say with the progress note
at the end of it having them do a verbal
handoff
so that we can understand what their
story is
so in that way we've
forced them
to generate a story
um
so every every time we've done that it's
been
sort of at
at the end of the task
asking them to verbalize what the
situation is
so in the case of the primary care
physicians
they're summarizing things and giving us
their
they're summarizing the story
verbally and then giving us
what their plan is and basically
entering it in um
so yes and no we force them
to generate a story right there's some
something that's not necessarily
realistic about that potentially
but we have i mean we have
they do they do generate one
yeah
thank you for the interesting talk uh
when you come back how long are you
going to be here and what are you going
to do
so
no that's i mean it's very interesting
so
so for sure we'll be back august through
november so about five months
one of the things that
is really
great about the group here
is that you're interested in similar
issues
but have
taken a variety of different
methodological approaches so where we've
been weaker in terms of observations and
interviews of things
you know that's an area where
you all are very strong at and so part
of the interest has been in
say something like this can we figure
out if
what people can verbalize as being
important lines up with what they
actually are looking at
so so there are some interesting things
there um
i've had i had a conversation with joan
ash this morning she brought up you know
a huge number of other interesting
things going on and then have other
conversations with people so
a little bit is to be determined but but
the initial the initial prompt is
besides you all being fun and nice
people
is that you're doing interesting things
in an area that's similar but
your strengths are in in different in
different areas
areas than mine
okay well thank you very
have another much